danielle simonnet conseillère de paris
et oratrice de la france insoumise
danielle simonnet merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors peut-être
pour commencer cette annonce du jour le
port du masque obligatoire dès la
semaine prochaine
le président avait parlé du premier
round comment comprenez vous cette
accélération dire écoutez le président
macro aura eu besoin de cinq mois pour
prendre conscience de la nécessité de
porter le masque parce que souvenez vous
au point de départ il nous expliquait
que le mas qui vient ça ne servait à
rien fallait pas le porter en vérité
parce qu'ils étaient incapables
ils avaient été incapables ainsi que les
gouvernements successifs de gérer les
stocks de masques et il était incapable
de faire en sorte qu'on ait une
production suffisante pour avoir toutes
et tous des masques alors évidemment il
faut que le port du masque soit
obligatoire dans les lieux publics c'est
un enjeu sanitaire
mais pour ce faire il faut garantir la
gratuité des masques parce
qu'aujourd'hui pour bon nombre de foyers
c'est un coût qui est problématique et
ce gouvernement ne veut pas prendre
conscience de l'urgence sociale dans
laquelle nous nous sommes entrés pour
beaucoup de familles il est très
difficile de devoir arbitrer entre eux
remplir le frigo ou payer loyer et les
masques viennent se rajouter comme un un
coup très problématique
alors crise sanitaire mais aussi de
nombreux dossiers dans le discours de
politique générale de jean castex plan
de relance décentralisation écologie ou
encore lutte contre le chômage des
thèmes qui vous sont chers sentez-vous à
un nouveau cap se dessiner
non il ya un nouveau cadre des liens
monsieur castex n'est pas là pour faire
un nouveau cap
monsieur castex est là pourquoi parce
que monsieur macron voulait un premier
ministre qui ne le fasse pas d'ombré ou
comme le disait d'ailleurs très bien
jean luc mélenchon dans son allocution à
l'assemblée nationale il a dit m'a
finalement monsieur castex de fera faire
moins bien que le monarque ce qui lui
laisse peu d'espacé mais on voit bien
est compris dans le discours de
maquereaux qu'il n'ya pas du tout de
vente et de de remettre en cause et de
réorienter la politique qui leur compte
mener souvenez-vous pendant le
confinement
ils nous avaient
quand même servis des mots assez forts
un monde se souvient du quoi qu'il en
coûte de la référence aux jours heureux
de la nécessité de se réinventer que
d'ailleurs lui-même son programme de
mandature on n'était pas adaptée à la
situation nouvelle mais pour autant ils
ont décidé de prendre exactement le même
cap
on est toujours sur les mêmes discours
libéraux regarder face à la crise de
l'emploi n'y a aucune volonté de
conditionner les aides aux entreprises
aux engagements écologiques et au fait
que ces entreprises ne supprime pas des
emplois de licencie pas donc on est en
train de subventionner des licenciements
enfin jeu c'est hallucinant et sur la
question par exemple de la lutte contre
le chômage des jeunes c'est toujours le
même les mêmes recettes libérales
baisser le coût du travail baisser ce
qu'ils appellent eux les charges alors
que l'on sait pertinemment que ce n'est
pas ainsi que l'on fait une politique de
relance
il faut au contraire aller dans une
logique de plein emploi par une très
vive irritation écologique pour faire
des créer des emplois là où c'est
nécessaire et qui répondent aux besoins
alors la question de la santé également
on se souvient de l'hommage aux
soignants le 14 juillet on se souvient
aussi des personnels hospitaliers qui
ont défilé dans la rue le même jour le
système de le plan de relance à prévoir
à 6 milliards d'euros dédiée à
l'investissement en ville et à l'hôpital
et 13 milliards de reprise de dette
hospitalière pour permettre aux
établissements de retrouver l'oxygène et
une capacité à investir c'est suffisant
selon vous
non le compte n'y est pas d'abord pour
plusieurs raisons premièrement les
personnels de santé réclame 300 euros
si même pas de l'augmentation c'est une
part de rattrapage or aujourd'hui ils
vont avoir à peine 183 euros ayant
puissant deux fois ce qui fait qu'ils
sont toujours bien en-deça de la moyenne
des salaires des professionnels
correspondants dans le dans dans l'union
européenne il faut savoir que ils sont
généralement à 6 ans voire à 800 euros
de moins un salaire de 600 à 800 euros
inférieur aux autres pays de l'union
européenne mais surtout le ségur et une
véritable imposture car il n'y a aucune
remise en cause des fermetures
d'hôpitaux des suppressions de lits moi
je le vois sur la région parisienne
on a toujours le problème de l'hôtel
dieu
de grâce qui a fermé de beauchamp déjà
de toutes ces réorganisations
restructurations
le secteur ne remet pas cela en cause 1
et puis l'eau ségur en profite pour par
ailleurs cassé la question des 35 heures
comme si l'annualisation du temps de
travail à les résoudre le problème de la
souffrance au travail et des conditions
de travail dans l'hôpital c'est vraiment
scandaleux parce que ce gouvernement
refuse d'entendre celles et ceux dont le
métier est essentiel pour sauver nos
vies donc je comprends et partage la
colère des soignants
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup danielle
simonnet d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes conseillère de
paris et oratrice de la france insoumise